[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها الجويه بدات يوم الاربعاء تدريبات
ع عريه مشتركه مع نظيرتها الاسرائيليه
بخصوص التحليق في الاجواء السوريه نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين ما هي
مبررات موسكو وتل ابيب لاقتسام الاجواء
السوريه وما موقف النظام السوري من هذه
الخطوه وما هي الانعكاسات العمليه
المحتمله لهذا التعاون الروسي الاسرائيلي
بشان التحرك في الاجواء
السوريه
[موسيقى]
باتت اذا قنوات تبادل المعلومات سالكه بين
مركز التحكم بالطيران الروسي في مطار محي
ميم بالساحل السوري ومركز قياده القوات
الجويه الاسرائيليه تلك احده من ثمرات
اتفاق روسي اسرائيلي فتح منذ يوم الاربعاء
الاجواء السوريه لاسرائيل بصوره قانونيه
تحت اعين النظام السوري الذي لم يعترض على
منحه حليفه المنقذ لما كان يسميه العدو
الاسرائيلي التقرير لزياد
بركات ثمه شيء كبير تغير اسرائيل نفسها
وهي ثابت في ادبيات حزبه اصبحت تغيب
تدريجيا في خطابات السيد ولقاءاته
التلفزيونيه تغير في الاولويات لم يقتصر
على الرجل بل شمل حلفائه في طهران يرسلون
الوفود والجنرالات الى دمشق لا للب بحث في
سبل تسخين الجبهه مع اسرائيل بل لامر اخر
فكلاهما حزب الله وطهران اصبح تحت مظله
واحده في سوريا وتلك هي روسيا التي تقصف
خصوم الاسد من الجو فيما هي تنسق وتطمئن
طرفا ثالثا ليس الاسد ولا السيد ولا الولي
الفقيه بل اسرائيل اين الممانعه اذا لم
يعد هذا سؤالا فثم معطيات على الارض تفضح
وتعري فبينما كان اخر الوفود الايرانيه في
دمشق لم تجد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه حرجا في
الاعلان عنما هو معروف ومتوقع القوات
الجويه الروسيه والاسرائيليه بدات بالفعل
تدريبات مشتركه في الاجواء السوريه تشمل
تبادل المعلومات حول حركتهما هناك وثمت
مركز تحكم روسي في اللاذقيه ينسق اولا
باول مع نظيره الاسرائيلي البلدان اذا في
الاجواء نفسها وتلك سوريا ينسقان لوجستيا
حول الاحداثيات والاهداف والتوقيت ويشمل
ذلك ما يسمى بالتنسيق
الكهرومغناطيسي فما الذي تبقى بعده خارج
التنسيق الحثيث وبالغ الدقه اذا تبقى
السخريه التي وسمت تعليقات معارضي الاسد
فلما لا تفعلها موسكو وتضم تل ابيب الى
محور الممانعه على ان ذلك هو ما يجري
فعليا على الارض في راي البعض تغير مفهوم
العدو لدى الممانعين فاصبح ما يسمى
الارهاب فخرجت اسرائيل من معادلات الصراع
القديمه اصبحت في موقف من يراقب تدخلت
روسيا بهواجس الامبراطوريه في الصراع
السوري فقصت وارسلت الجنرالات لنجده الاسد
ولكن بعد ان وضعت نتنياهو في صوره ما يحدث
وسيحدث وكانت النتيجه ان الرجل ابلغ باولى
الغارات الروسيه في سوريا قبل ساعه على
الاقل من وقوعها وبقبول ه ذلك اصبحت تل
ابيب شريكا صام
يحتفظ بحق النقد ربما والحال هذه لا باس
من تدريبات تحفظ لكل طرف حصته وتستبق خططه
وذاك قد يعني امرين ان موسكو تقر بحق
الطيران الاسرائيلي بالوجود في الاجواء
السوريه وانها من يحتاج التنسيق مع
الاسرائيليين فيما لو وسعت حملتها الجويه
لتشمل الجنوب السوري وصولا الى القنيطره
على احدهم يسهل عمل الاخر وربما يكمله اما
الممانعه فضد الشعب السوري ومن ناصره
فقط موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
لندن الكاتب الصحفي السوري بسام جعاره من
بيروت الكاتب الصحفي يونس عوده ومن باريس
خطار ابو دياب الباحث في المعهد الدولي
للدراسات الجيوسياسيه اهلا بكم جميعا
استاذ خطار ابو دياب ما مبررات موسكو وتل
ابيب اقتسام الاجواء السوريه
برايك هناك اذا زحمه مرور في الاجواء
السوريه السياده اصبحت في خبر كان منذ
فتره طويله والان تتكرس هذا التزاحم راينا
كيف ان الطائرات الامريكيه والروسيه لم
تتوصل بعد الى تفاهم هناك مفاوضات المساله
اذا ليست بالاقتصار اسرائيل تفتش عن امنها
هي منذ فتره طويله ت تصول وتجول في اجواء
سوريا ولبنان وهذا ليس من الاسرار وعندما
كانت
تقوم بغرا كان النظام السوري يقول دوما
سيكون الرد في الوقت المناسب ولم ياتي هذا
الوقت الان نحن لا نفاجا لانه منذ العام
2012 منذ زياره فلاديمير بوتين الى
اسرائيل اتضح جليا ان هناك تنسيق روسي
اسرائيلي يراعي مصالح الطرفين الدول في
هذا الموضوع ليس جمعيات خيريه لكن كل ما
يمر هو على حساب الشعب السوري ربما يوما
على حساب وحده سوريا على حساب كل الاقليم
يمكن ان ان تكون هذه الترتيبات ان بين
موسكو و واسرائيل اليوم سمعنا ايضا ان
روسيا تفتش عن تنسيق مع تركيا وهناك تنسيق
مع امريكا كاننا امام تقاسم مناطق نفوذ
ليس فقط على الارض بل في الجو وهذا يوحي
اذا كما قلت بنوع من احتدام الصراع حول
سوريا وفي سوريا من نوع من لعبه امم كبيره
تدور على ارضها
واظن انا اخشى الاسوا في هذا الموضوع لانه
رغم كل الكلام عن التدريبات وعمليات
التنسيق هذا لا يعني ان هناك في لحظه ما
بعد كل هذا التقاطع من المصالح الذي سمح
باستمرار هذه الحرب وهذا النزيف بعد كل
هذا التقاطع الامريكي الاسرائيلي الايراني
الروسي لكل هدفه في الموضوع ليس من
الضروره ان يكون نفس الهدف كان هناك ولذلك
اظن بعد هذا التقاطع امكانيه الاشتباك
تبقى موجوده سيد يونس عوده برايك لماذا لم
نسمع اعتراض من قبل النظام السوري على ما
منحه حليفه الروسي لعدوه المفترض
الاسرائيلي يعني هذه
فرضيه من عندك انه ليس هناك اعتراض او
هناك اعتراض اولا لنعرف جوهر الموضوع
روسيا دوله وموجوده الان طائراتها على
الارض السوريه وتقوم بضرب مواقع
الارهابيين وهناك تحالف
دولي ايضا تحت عنوان مكافحه الارهاب وهو
لا يقوم بهذه المهمه روسيا لا تريد ان
تصطدم باحد تريد ان تحيد ما امكن من الدول
في خلال عملياتها الجويه التي تستهدف
الارهابيين
الغريب انه يركز على هذه النقطه ولا يركز
مثلا على الدول العربيه التي تريد ان تقيم
علاقات مع اسرائيل مثلا وتريد ان تشتري
منها منظومات صاروخيه وتحول وتواصل عملق
يكون ما وراء الخبر عن هذا الموضوع
ونستضيف وتدلي بدلوك الان نتحدث عن ليس
فرضيه مني عن ان اسرائيل هي مفترض عدو
للنظام السوري الذي يحمل شعار الممانعه و
هذه هذا العدو هذا العدو ينسق مع الحليف
الروسي في الاجواء وحتى في البحر لماذا لم
يعترض النظام السوري على ذلك برا يعني هو
هو عدو هو
عدو هو عدو بلا شك عدو وسيبقى العدو الاول
ودوما هو جزء من هذا الصراع يعني في اداره
العمليات دوما يمكن ان تكون هناك اولويات
لكن اسرائيل تبقى العدو الاول والنهائي
ي يشرع له يعني ان يقوم
برحلاته فوق الاجواء
الس من قال انه سيقوم برحلاته هذا استنتاج
هناك يعني بكل
الاحوال ق غير
صحيح ساحاول ان اجيب ط طب تقول من قال
يعني كل كل معلومه كل معلومه اسالك عنها
تشكك بالمعلومه اص حتى لا ترد على على
السؤال هنالك الكثير من الغارات التي تنفذ
كم مره انتهكت اسرائيل الاجواء السوريه كم
مره انت ادرى مني بذلك سيد يونس نعم كث
كثيرا كثيرا كثيرا كثيرا كثيرا انا لا
اقول ان اسرائيل لم تنتهك الاجواء وهذا
يعني بكل بساطه ان اسرائيل هي العدو هي
التي تقصف المواقع السوريه عندما تحصل
اشتباكات على الحدود بين الج الجيش العربي
السوري وبين الارهابيين وتسقط قذيفه في
المنطقه المحتله من الجولان ترد اسرائيل
على مواقع الجيش السوري وليس على
الارهابيين حتى لو اطلقت من الجانب
الارهابي هذا يعني بكل بساطه ان اسرائيل
لا تزال تحدد من هو العدو وايضا سوريا ت
تحدد من هو العدو وهو اسرائيل بكل بساطه
ان عمليه التنسيق التي سيد يونس نعم اذكرك
ب مجددا موضوع الحلقه قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قواتها الجويه بدات يوم
الاربعاء تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه مع
نظيرتها الاسرائيليه بخصوص التحليق في
الاجواء السوريه المرحله الاولى بدات
الاربعاء والمرحله الثانيه تبدا اليوم هذا
موضوع
الحلقه الخميس نعم نعم يعني انا اقول لك
يعني دعيني اقول لك يعني هناك فرق كبير
بين كلمه اجراءات وتدريبات هناك اجراءات
نعم هذا صحيح كلمه تدريبات هي غير دقيقه
في في هذا الموضوع تحصل اجراءات وهي
لتحييد اسرائيل في هذا الموضوع الصراع
عندما تكون الطائرات الروسيه في الاجواء
السوريه لا تريد ان يكون هناك اي طائره
اخرى اذا حصل ان هناك طائرات تجري عمليه
تنسيق لحتى لا تشتبك هذه الطائرات وهذا
شيء معلن وليس جديدا وانا اعتقد ان هذا من
الذكاء بمكان ان تحيد ال حتى لا تحصل
عمليات اشتباك والتركيز على الهدف الاساسي
وبالتالي ان اذا كنت في اداره الصراع ان
تقسم العدو هذا شيء جيد كما اعتقد طيب سيد
بسام جعاره هذا شي شيء جيد ومن الذكاء ان
يحيد ما
قولك يعني اسمحي لي وضح بعض الامور اولا
بدي اعيد تذكيركم باللي قاله رامي مخلوف
بعد ايام من اندلاع الثوره عندما قال ان
امن اسرائيل من امن دمشق هذا اولا ثانيا
عندما حلقت طائرات التحالف اعتبر وزير
خارجيه النظام ان هذا التعليق تعليق يشكل
عدوانا سافرا على الارض السوريه ولكنه لم
يقل ذلك عندما حلق الطائرات الاسرائيليه
امس واليوم في الاجواء السوريه بالتنسيق
مع الطيران الروسي ثالثا عندما قال بوتين
في خلال استقباله نتنياهو انه يقر
بالمصالح الاسرائيليه في سوريا قال ذلك
علنا ونقلته كل وكالات الانباء ولم يعترض
النظام ولا ايران ولا حزب الله بل رحبوا
بالتنسيق اللي بدي اقوله بكل وضوح نحن
الان امام تحالف واضح امريكي اسرائيل روسي
اسرائيلي ايراني اكثر من ذلك خلال زياره
نتنياهو لموسكو قدم لموسكو ال بنك اهداف
يتضمن
1550 هدف 700 لجبه النصره 300 لتنظيم
الدوله 550 لفصائل الجيش الحر ايضا تم
الاتفاق على اعلام السلطات الاسرائيليه او
القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه باي تحرك في
الجنوب ليتم التنسيق بمعنى هناك ليس تنسيق
بل هناك حلف يقاتل معا ماذا يعني ان
يقدموا بنجا اهداف هذا يعني ان اسرائيل
تقاتل مع النظام ولكن هذا النظام المجرم
لم يطلق اي تصريح على الاطلاق اكثر من ذلك
ان حسن نصر الله رحب بالتدخل العسكري
الروسي وهو يعلم تمام ان روسيا قالت صراحه
انها تقر بالمصالح الاسرائيليه في سوريا
ماذا يعني ذلك هل يحتاج الى اجتهاد بعدين
هذا الكلام اللي عم نقوله هي تصريحات
قالها المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الدفاع
طيب كان هنالك انباء تتحدث او يعني من قبل
الروس انباء تتحدث عن نوع من التقارب بين
الامريكي والروسي حول مساله التعاون في ما
يسمى مكافحه الارهاب في سوريا ولكن لاحقا
عندما قال بوتين انهم رفضوا استقبال وفد
روسي في امريكا نفت الانباء هذه هل يمكن
ان نستنتج من ال بعض الاحاديث عن تقارب في
هذا في هذا المجال عن ان ربما ربما قد
يكون الامريكيون قالوا للروس نعم اوكي
ادخلوا ولكن نسقوا مع الاسرائيليين يعني
حليفكم الامريكي كمعارض سوريه هو ايضا
موافق على هذا الموضوع على الاقل روسيا
وقفت وقفه صلبه مع حليفها لكن الامريكيون
الامريكيين عولت عليهم ولم يفعلوا شيئا
لبل قد يكونوا ايضا تامروا
ضدكم يعني سمحيلي يقول لك الامريكان ليسوا
حليف على الاطلاق وبعتقد سمعتيني من اربع
سنوات وانا اقول ان الاداره الامريكيه
عدوا للشعب السوري عندما كنا نقول هذا
الكلام كنا ننطلق من معلومات يعني عندما
تقدم روسيا السلاح وكل شيء للنظام وتمنع
امريكا وصول المضاضات الجويه للشعب السوري
ماذا يعني ذلك الا يعني ان هناك تواطؤ
هناك تقاطع مصالح لو كانت امريكا تريد
الان ازدار روسيا تستطيع لا نقول تقدم بل
تسمح للدول الشقيقه بارسال صواريخ للشعب
السوري وباكد لك سوف تسقط الطائرات
الروسيه كالذباب كما سقطت في افغانستان
ولكن هذا التواطؤ هو الذي يمنع الان هي
اوكلت لحليفه الاسرائيلي مهمه التنسيق
وتقول امريكا علنا انها تريد توريط الروس
في سوريا وهذا الامر يتم على حساب دماء
السوريين امريكا ليست حليفا هي دافعت عن
السفير السابق الامريكي في سوريا كان
متواجدا مع وفد المعارضه في جنف مثلا في
جناف اثنين فشل لاحقا لكن كان هنالك كانان
التنسيق على يعني اعلى قدم
معه فرض يعني امريكا فرضت نفسها رائس
قائمه اصدقاء الشعب السوري كنا نقول دائما
من يملك مثل هؤلاء الاصدقاء لا يحتاج الى
اعداء على الاطلاق يعني من انقذ بشار من
القتل في عام 2012 سكتت امريكا تركت
لايران تخالف قرار مجلس الامن بارسال قوات
وارسال اسلحه وكل شيء على مراه ومشهد بل
تاتي الطائرات الايرانيه عبر الاجواء
العراقيه التي تحتشد بها الطائرات
الامريكيه بمعنى هناك موافقه امريكيه
صريحه الكوبيون جاؤوا الى سوريا
الايرانيون جاؤوا الى سوريا ما هب ودب
كلهم يعني ياتي الى سوريا بموافقه امريكيه
من هو الذي قال ان امريكا حليف
طيب نواصل هذا النقاش ولكن بعد الفاصل
فابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد سيد خطار ابوب ما
هي الانعكاسات المحتمله لهذا التنسيق
الروسي
الاسرائيلي استذ خطار ما هي تسمعنا استاذ
خطار اسمعك السؤال هو ما هي الانعكاسات
المحتمله لهذا التعاون الروسي الاسرائيلي
بشان التحرك في الاجواء
السوريه
اعتقد ان الوضع في سوريا يتجه نحو المزيد
من
الاستقطاب ليس من الضروره ان تكون الاحلاف
نهائيه هناك متغيرات في هذا الوضع الصعب
كان من المنتظر في الاساس كان السيد
اوباما يعول مع توقيع الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران على تطبيع الوضع في المنطقه وعلى
بناء منظومه امنيه جديده وتركيب الوضع فاد
بالسيد بوتين يستبق الامر ويصل الى دمشق
ويقول الامر لي هذا هو الوضع الجديد الوضع
الجديد الان هناك امر واقع جديد خلقته
روسيا على الساحه السوريه وليس بالضروره
ان ان يكون حلفاء روسيا من الذين رحبوا هم
الان يتعاونون ولكن في النهايه هناك
انقلاب في الموازين ولذا لا اظن ان هذا
الامر مع اسرائيل يتخطى مساله التنسيق
التكتيكي في مساله عدم الاصطدام في
الاجواء يمكن ان يكون كما قلت في لحظه
هناك هدف مشترك في عدم تبديل النظام لكن
الان نحن دخلنا مرحله اخرى مرحله اعاده
تركيب المنطقه واظن هنا الاهداف ستختلف
السيد بوتين في موقع جيد لان اوباما لا
يريد ان يعمل اليوم لاحظتم كيف ان اوباما
اضطر لنسيان تعهداته والابقاء على قواته
في افغانستان انا برايي اوباما سيضطر ايضا
للعوده الى الساحه السوريه بشكل او باخر
هناك اذا تحدي في هذا الموضوع وهناك
محاوله لاعاده رسم الخطوط واظن بان
المصالح الاسرائيليه والروسيه تتقارب في
بعض الاشياء ولا تتقاطع في اشياء اخرى ال
الخلاصه بالنسبه لي اننا امام احتدام في
الوضع السوري وليس امام تسهيل في الحل
سياسي هذا التدخل الروسي بدل ان يسهل الحل
السياسي سيعقد الحل السياسي لانه من دون
حد ادنى من الوفاق الاقليمي والدولي لن
يتم الامر محاوله كسر تركيا الان وردود
فعل اردوغان سنرى كيف سيتم التعامل مع هذا
الوضع علينا التطلع اذاا الى هذه المنطقه
بالذات واظن ان الاسابيع القادمه هي
اسابيع صعبه لان بوتين يعول على انهاء كل
العمليات في سوريا قبل عيد الميلاد
الارثوذكسي واظن انه حتى الان لم ينجح في
تحقيق اي الاهداف التي اتى من اجلها اي
تدعيم النظام السوري وارغام المعارضه على
الاستسلام بشكل او باخر طيب سيد يونس عوده
مصطلح الممانعه هل لازال قائما في ظل امر
الواقع الجديد الذي تحدث عنه خطار ابو جاب
وما سماه ايضا انقلاب في الموازين وفي ظل
مثلا ما نشرته صحيفه السفير عن مصادر
امنيه اسرائيليه تقول انه اذا توفرت
لاسرائيل معلومات دقيقه حول نيات جهات
معاديه تنفيذ هجمات ضد اهداف روسيه سوف
تزوده بها والعكس صحيح وبان بوتين قال
لنتنياهو اطمئنك اصلا الجيش السوري الان
غير قادر على فتح جبهه الجولان ولذلك يتم
التنسيق على اعلى مستوى بينهما مصطلح
الممانعه هل بات
واردا نعم
يعني بات وردا هو اصبح اكثر
وهناك مصطلح مقاومه مقاومه هذا المشروع لا
تزال مستمره انا اعتقد ان ا طبعا مثل ما
قال السيد خطار ابو ذياب ان الدخول الروسي
على الخط قلب الموازين طبعا اصبح
ا تحالف المقاومه اذا او حلف المقاومه بات
اقوى بكثير والان هناك ست جبهات مفتوحه
داخل الارض السوريه في ست اتجاهات ل
بلورت الهجوم الكبير هذا يعني بكل بساطه
ان الحلف الاخر حلف الاشرار اذا جز حلف
المقاومه يتضمن ايضا تل ابيب سيد يونس
بهذا المعنى حلف المقاومه يتضمن ايضا تل
ابيب دعني انقل اليك ما نشرته ايضا صحيفه
السفير في بيروت عندك الصفقه التي حملها
نتنياهو اصلا لبوتين تتضمن قيام اسرائيل
بتقديم معلومات استخباراتيه لموسكو مقابل
احباط الروس لمحاولات تنفيذ عمليات بين
هلالين ارهابيه ضد اسرائيل يعني العمليات
الارهابيه هنا في هذ في هذه الحاله هي
عمليات حزب الله لانه اسرائيل تعتبر لان
اسرائيل تعتبر ان العمليات الارهابيه ضدها
هي من قبل حزب حزب الله هذا
تفسير من من يقوم بعمليه اسرائيل بالنسبه
اليك الان يعني لا هذا تفسير طيب فسر لي
انت من من المقصود بعمليات الارهابيه ضد
اسرائ فون هناك فلسطينيون يقومون يا سيدتي
في سوريا سي هناك فلسطينيون يقومون
بعمليات الان فلسطين تشتعل فلسطين تشتعل
لا اتحدث عن غزه وضف اتحدث عن الداخل
السوري لكن هل
يمكن ان يبلغ حزب الله هذا وذاك عندما
سيقوم بعمليات هذا كلام يعني انا لا اعتقد
ان جهه يمكن لديها النيه او ستقوم بعمليه
ان تبلغ هذا الطرف او ذاك مهما على كعبه
ومه روس
بهاب يكون يعني حزب الله لن يخبر لكن لو
عرفت استخبارات الروسيه ببخ اسرا لا يعني
انا لا يمكن ان
اتحدث يعني لا تريديني ان اكمل على الاقل
ادعيني مره واحده اكمل
الفكره بكل بساطه في هذا العمل يعني الان
هناك الحرب على الارض السوريه عندما تقولي
ان اسرائيل قدمت او كما قال السيد بسام
جعاره 1500 هدف يعني هو يعرم من ضمن
المخابرات الاسرائيليه هذه المعلومات ليس
من مكان اخر يعني هناك استنتاجات هذا
الكلام نقلته منقول عن اسرائيل وليس صحيفه
السفير ما نشرته نقلته عن من من هو الذي
كتب هذا السيناريو هذه هي المساله بكل
بساطه انا اقول ان الان حلف الممانعه كما
قلتي هو او حلف المقاومه يزداد قوه
واسرائيل هي العدو الاول وستبقى العدو
الاول هناك معركه كبيره على هذه المساحه
الجغرافيه روسيا شريك في هذ معركه ضد
الارهاب ويمكن ان تتوسع المعركه اكثر
لتطال اماكن
اخر اكثر اذا سيد بسام جعاره في حال توسع
الحمله الجويه وصولا الى القنيطره مع ما
يعني ذلك ضرب لما يسمى بمعارض معتدله هناك
لان هناك
تواجدها هل هذا يعني ان التنسيق يطال
ضربات على الحدود هناك مع اسرائيل بدون ان
تتدخل اسرائيل تسهيلا او منعا لتسهيل وصول
المعارضه الى ريف
دمشق بيقول اولا بنك الاهداف الذي تحدثت
عنه ذكرته صحيفه السفير بدون تفاصيل انا
ايضا انا بدي اذكر انا قلت عبر شاشتكم من
اسبوعين عن غرفه العمليات الجويه المشتركه
بعتقد اذا رجعتوا راح تلاقوا هذا الكلام
بمعنى ما نقوله هو معلومات موامن اصدقاء
في المعارضه الروسيه نعلم تمام كل شيء
عندما يتحدث عن حلف المقاومه يعني لماذا
يتجاوز تحالف اسرائيل مع روسيا وروسيا
متحالفه تدافع عن الحرس الثوري الا يراني
في الاجواء نعم هناك حلف واضح رسمي تحالف
اسرائيلي ايراني روسي وحسب الله اداه
صغيره في هذا التحالف اللي بدقول له بكل
وضوح دخول القوات الروسيه الى سوريا هو
اعلان رسمي بهزيمه ايران بهزيمه حزب الله
بهزيمه بشار الاسد والا لما اتى الروس انا
بستغرب لماذا لم يطلب بشار من اولاد عمه
اليهود ان ياتوا بدلا من ارسال الروس عبر
الاف الكيلومتر
طح يعني هم بشرونا ان الروس جا نحن اليوم
ميوم 16 ما الذي حصل على الارض مجزر
دبابات مجزره اليوم ايضا للقوات قوات
النظام وايران ثلاثه من قاده الحرس الثوري
الايراني ثلاثه من قاده حزب الله ينحرون
على الارض بعد 16 يوم ورح نشوف بالاسابيع
القادمه كيف سينتحر
اشكركم جميع عن ضيوفي الكرام واشكر
متابعتكم مشاهدينا والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء